[Musique]
pendant les cinq jours qu'a duré
l'opération vous n'êtes pas arrêter de
fumer je l'aimé encore plus assassines
et vous monsieur moi j'étais pas mal
j'ai toujours filmé j'aime bien le
savoir je peux marcher canettes étiez le
docteur vous disait de vous arrêter
maintenant qu'est ce que vous feriez moi
je ne parle pas je filme en général
j'aime j'ai mal le sens bien
ça vous fait pas mal non le film the
pocket savoie personnel vous êtes en
bonne santé
vous pensez que c'est pas trop mauvais
pour la santé de fumée propre moi pas
pour vous vu aucun cas payer vous fumez
combien de paquets par jour
depuis l'opération de l'année dernière
vous ne fumez plus nom n'avait plus
jamais touché une cigarette non en fait
j'ai essayé de fumer mais j 6 2 gouttes
insein s'y arrête mais je prépare fumer
c'était impossible a tant que vous ne
fumez plus comment vous sentez mieux
ça vous a pas rendu un peu nerveux au
début or les premiers points mettant
ainsi les paumes et là ça ça énerve vous
avez beaucoup de vos camarades qui ont
cessé de fumer aussi il y avait environ
une dizaine oui il y en a peut-être que
deux ou trois qui fument plus maintenant
madame cette opération anti tabac qu'est
ce que ça représentait pour vous si vous
à faire à n'est plus le même oui
monsieur
40% de baisse sur les 22 les autres
années
parce qu'il ya beaucoup de gens qui
n'ont pas repris vraiment définitivement
qui sont beaucoup le salaire surtout
dans les jeunes venus monsieur parce que
vraiment pas ça du pourquoi leur faire
du bien sans doute ce n'était pas dans
les personnes âgées aussi marc fait
quand même que ce qu'ils font là passez
vous achète du chewing gum ou des
cachous n'ont
pas beaucoup dans vos d'epargne faudra
penser vous reconvertir la vie qu'est ce
que ça vous a été difficile de vous
arrêter avec les premiers jours ça a été
un peu dur me faire j'avais passé un
contrat avec mon petit fils là que
vous avez fait ça pour pour le jeu oui
peut-être et depuis les premiers jours
de l'opération anti tabac vous avez
résister à résister jusqu'au aujourd'hui
sa phase a offert non mais vous n'avez
plus envie de fumer ah non non
maintenant c'est fini ceci dit ah les
premiers temps c'était un peu dur que
soient les moyens peu qu'est ce que vous
faisiez vous si je vous suis fier des
cachous au un peu tout quelques bonbons
que quelques n'importe quoi vos
camarades ne se sont pas moqués d'eux
vous ont pas du tout pas du tout il n'y
a pas aucune raison ils voudront pas
demander comment vous faisiez pour
arriver à tenir le coup
rabat s'il y en a clairement demandé
mais comment se fait-il que tu résistes
comme ça j'ai des mois c'est le contact
s'est passé avec mon petit fils parce
que je dis pas que je veux être pas
essuyé deux refus mais sans ça alors si
le petit fils s'était pas arrêté de
fumer peut-être joué vous peut-être que
j'aurais quand même s'ils reculent même
peu j'en avais envie navin il a fallu
tenir le contrat est maintenant c'est
bien terminé puisque je n'ai aucune
envie de refus mais aucune au kinoïde ce
qu'il ne faut pas faire c'est de ne
jamais prendre une cigarette de ce que
m'ont offert vous savez surtout au début
il est comme je me disais allez pas aux
annonceurs des époques pas de ça
pas de ça c'est surtout là qu'il faut
faire attention mais aujourd'hui c'est
un jour spécial pour la télévision si je
vous offre une cigarette ou l'apprenez
non pas du tout allez un petit effort
maintenant non non non non vous
commencez la fille si vous voulez que la
faire voir la télévision en double à
prévoir mais je ne voudrais pas c'est
sûr bravo c'est sûr bon courage raconte
iv et ben je continuerai merci
[Musique]